歡迎收看最佛心幽默的財經節目
理財達人秀 我是李昭華
今天是星期五這個禮拜
漲了前四天 今天稍微止步囉
46000點沒有守住小跌了210點
不過最近市場的氣氛
錢是有回到太古來的
原因就在美國現在的升息預期
已經越降越低
包括CPI和昨天晚上的PPI的指數
都是低於市場的預期
或是符合市場預期
所以這導致
美元也相較之下比較走弱
台幣今天強生有到一腳
所以今天外資又大買了台股400多億
連續兩天大買
是不是真的叫做
外資要回頭
我們有提醒一件事
整個台股也許資金結構有所改變了
畢竟外資賣了那麼久
不過漲到46000點的附近
確實也可以看到
例如投信有一點停看停的味道跑出來
那很多的股票談到這邊
今天也叫做開高走低
似乎都在等待下個禮拜一個新的佈局契機
所以我們今天要來幫大家全面檢驗
下個禮拜的策略佈局
好來歡迎今天三位來賓
第一位是盈利投資的中國中
總總都有提醒指數來到45000點以上
就有可能慢慢慢慢的面臨到壓力
現在看起來果然是有一些
但是外資的回頭
會不會也形成一股新的資金勢力呢
等一下來好好拆解
台幣美元跟外資回流
到底有沒有要留意什麼
不過今天的話
我們看到有一些法說
顯然變成法會
例如工業電腦的話
但是延華龍頭卻是創新高的路上
因此今天中大膽說
在這樣的局勢裡面
選擇被措殺的IPC工業電腦
也會是一個安穩的好選擇
第二位是我們的國家級基金超盤手黃豐凱凱哥
凱哥也在看喔
這個投信確實有一些確佈的狀況
甚至有一些好股票
明明之前他們好愛的
現在卻接連砍出
等一下凱哥有一個獨家清單
叫做投信的錯殺股
說錯殺要有理由要有證據
他會說投信不一定是真心想要賣這些股票
另外我們來看到
MACI調整台股的權重式
三聲以及挪威主權基金也回來採買的話
有哪些外資看好的股票
等一下也一定告訴您囉
第三位是我們的籌碼增加
全正小哥
前面講外資跟投信
小哥當然幫我們看
主力和大戶
今天群聯法說會後
吃了一根將近9%的下跌
發生什麼事
單計賺118還不夠嗎
關鍵就在籌碼中
整個記憶體的狀況好壞不一樣
而大立光今天也是個回答
不過以CPO的代表來說
CPO的籌碼等一下一起幫您看
以及全陣波段大戶來了
來了小哥今天的獨門菜
等一下端上來
全陣大戶在買什麼
所以今天外資投信主力大戶
籌碼我們全部都幫您看
首先有請鍾大膽
是
今天禮拜五
又下跌
等一下
你就是要禮拜五上漲
其他四天疊沒關係
但是這禮拜跟您做對了
前四天上漲
前四天疊
但因為財壁今天強生
連續兩天外資都是大買
就等投信了
主流已經換人當了
但是我們看一下IPC
研華代創高
化汗今天吃了一根疊停板
是 我們看今天的市場上
會這麼樣的強勢
或者甚至是在這個禮拜
外資會那麼強勢
當然最主要還是有一些跟升息的部分
稍微趨緩的這個聲音出來
上次包括美國的CPI
這個跌超乎大家預期
那這次公佈了PPI
意外的持平
所以兩個的物價指數
告訴大家通膨壓力趨緩
那我們可以發現
它這次是低預期
然後這次也是低預期
尤其也比上個月的數字來的低
那我們看台幣的部分
在這次當中也從32塊半
在今天盤中曾經散見31
是 強生
那大概尾盤之後
還是受到32.046
換句話說外資在這個禮拜的
積極的買超
確實在臺幣這部分
看到有個明顯的升值
所以如果正常來講
這個禮拜應該是股匱
都是算是有利於投資人
那我們來看臺股的部分
在這個禮拜臺股來講是
量縮價漲 量縮價漲
這樣是好還是不好
坦白講量縮價漲不要什麼
這次的滿盤主要是法人的滿盤
那投資人的參與度沒有那麼高
那就一部分 收費量是4.68兆
那我上次講過了
預估會一到兩個禮拜的時間
會反彈放上工 我上次講過了
那已經兩週了
上次提醒大家
好把握這是多頭的上工契機
兩個禮拜我覺得有把握
那第三個禮拜我就沒把握
因為這次會上漲是雙I的效應
就CPI降
然後MSCI升
助攻來到46500點的附近
那接下來就考驗什麼
真實力我特別把它框起來
如果投資朋友已經把整個今年這個
大盤從5月份這邊來看
46500點這個位置
收盤
收盤有在46,500點以上的
各位 你看好像很多
只有三天
是
換句話說今天盤中最高的要46,400點
大家就很清楚了
台紙已經接近到
真正的壓力區了
我個人認為說
45,000可否順利上攻
站穩
你說現在不是已經達到45,000點以上嗎
坦白講
過去我們說技術分析有個叫做
百分之三的測試
什麼叫百分之三測試
就是說
4萬5的3%以上
大概就是46350要佔五三天
換句話說
盤中曾經有來到46400
有來挑戰
但是呢
終究我剛才提到過
46500點
這個位置能夠佔五
到目前為止只有三天
換句話說
要看三天
今天第一次挑戰
失敗還沒有
所以我覺得這部分是要去觀察
那上次的前波大量4.8218
就這個禮拜
各位看量也知道
黑這麼黑
那現在的量呢
目前來講只有4.68兆
這邊有7.75兆
所以換句話說
不容易馬上就供上去
如果你要買的話
我個人認為是要等到
有拉回的時候
那當然另外一種有人說
會不會直接供上去
有 量如果放大
有兩種性能效
第一 外置持續在大買
那臺幣就持續往31塊半
這樣子就有可能
這是第一種現象
第二種現在就是
接下來你就要常常看一個雲霄飛車了
像今天就有看到一些小雲霄飛車了
那所以我想
只有這種兩種情形
一種就是
外資就一次乾脆做到底
往上攻 往上拉
另外一種就是大幅增到
開地已經來到90附近
相對上漲空間有限
也確實跟這個相呼應
那我上次有提到過了
這十年當中七月份如果下跌
八月份一定會出現跌升反彈
所以在這位置我記得我上次
送給大家四個字嘛
大跌不賣嘛
叫你買一定不會買
大跌不賣至少
把你抓住你沒有賣
那現在你要賣隨便你
但是怕你現在又
捨不得賣
那我們之前看過的數字就是
七月份如果跌八月份反彈會上漲
但是他的漲幅不容易達到
前一個月的跌幅的一半
換句話說7月份跌幅6.51
現在目前8月份已經把它吃下
看起來8月份我認為
後半個月會有漲多的修正
大概這一波的轉折點
應該會在下個禮拜的8月19號
期貨結算前兩三天
應該留下本波的轉折點
因為這一波反導已經到了
轉折係數以下部隊
13天左右了
那終於是這一波的上季最強的
已經來到季線跟景線位置
那今天的上市沒有低於昨天的低點
但上櫃已經低於昨天的低點
所以我孩子強調
不管是就上櫃或就上市來講
這個時候真的叫考驗
生實力這時候真的能夠上漲
就是主流股的主流
一種情況就是你在找落後補漲的
那我們看一下美國的走勢
這波我認為是主要走跌升版談
是因為美國道儒只是追星創新高
但在這個禮拜沒有創新高
反倒是科技股的往上走
換句話說
這禮拜的反應的叫做
對利率的敏感度的科技股
因為不升息
所以科技股的走比較強
但是不要忘記
稻窮難抽谷
這些也是要跟利率有關
難道他們利率沒關嗎
換句話說
多頭的格局沒有往上攻
然後這邊是跌升反彈
所以我覺得比較偏向是跌升反彈
這波大鵬
我認為不會一口氣往上攻
所以我想未來的部分
我認為主流股
可能會先休息一下
也談了一半
包括像台積電或老AOA這些
可能漲多了 稍微休息一下
接下來可能就是什麼
飛電或題材股
那包括像飛電就軍工
今天的軍工
那或題材的機器人的部分
類似這個部分
大家要接棒嘛 對不對
軍工的話
其實之前的總統有提到
有時候市場主流在換
軍工會跑出來接棒
今天立院有通過一個無人機條例
等於不凍結了
所以今天的軍工大漲
可是延續性您覺得好不好
很好 我記得我上禮拜來講的時候
更各位大家提到過
總預算已經到了敏感期了
這個在野黨要黨好像也不好
然後執政黨 這個預算沒過
他也很痛苦 兩個都有壓力
所以到時候一定會因為一個協商版
果然是這禮拜真的有協商版
那因為他這邊已經沉澱一段時間
我個人是覺得比較有機會
在做一個跌升反彈
都一樣 全部的純入的類股
都走跌升反彈
那現在目前比較主流股對象
除了低潤記憶體外
那另外一個就是IPC
好 龍頭炎滑
像IPC 我今天為什麼會講IPC
因為說各位發現IPC的炎滑
今天是雖然拉回
對 小壓回
坦白講 如果他這樣上漲
然後盤中的這樣變動的話
還所謂五日線表示什麼
他算是強
那因為他是龍頭類股
如果今天化汗跟他倒過來
那就不是這麼說法了
因為最主要是
龍頭骨是目前還是多頭的格局
那其他類股
各股有一些部分影響的話
那就是要去做一個觀察
所以我想今天有包括一些
炎華 化汗 四星科 飛捷 靈華這些
我看它的EPS
或者YOLI的部分
都算是有成長
而且本益比多再20倍以下
那這個說炎華比較大一點
那我們來看一下
今天市場上最關心就是化汗的部分
化汗吃了一根蝶蝶
我們來講他前幾天公佈的財報
也不算難看
一PS7.15元
計幀有38.8 年增74%
創價歷史的次高
但因為零組件的漲價
所以他第二屆毛利跌破20%
創價這四個季度的低點
但是還是比他去年同級的18.2
來得高
但本益比我大概算一算
其實今年有機會算23塊錢的話
其實本益比不到20倍
那下午今天告有法說會
昨天才爆完 今天馬上為了他的股價爆去
上半年一批史已經達到12.31
然後上下半年預估會45到55
其實關鍵來說 下半年的成績應該更好
所以大概推算的話
其實跟我之前在預估也差不多
有那種可能性
目前在手訂單
這個我們之前都講過2550億
那這個部分三大市業會實際做一個發展
那併購這個空儲
這個德國的大概預算會5塊錢
而且這個部分會在明年的效應
會開始出現
所以如果你從它的抽K線
發現紅 黑 紅 黑C
是高原的盤整
那當然最主要這邊是有一個大量
它這四根其實波動蠻大
對 阿C 坦白說
又回到原來七張點的位置
所以我個人認為說
其實是毛利綠面怎樣
其實他也回到原來的
七張點的位置
所以我個人覺得
如果是你手中有的
不用太緊張
因為這邊也看有一樣
因為沒有我倒是覺得
可以做一個買點的位置
因為都已經回到原來的這個原點
換句話說先前這邊的修正
可能有再反映到毛利率的部分
那我們今天就講另外兩家公司
就講飛捷跟靈華
因為靈華講過了
那我們今天講這家公司是飛捷的部分
那IPC我會再講出了
龍頭的靈華往上創高之外
另外就是下禮拜有機器人長
機器人長飛捷跟靈華
他們都剛好跟機器人有關
我們知道現在大家把重點都判在
這個上銀這些等等
比較算是大家馬上想像的機器人
但是這些也有一些機器人
也相關題材的部分
我們先從飛姐來講
他這幾年從原本的存硬體製造的部分
轉到軟硬體的這個智能方法
所以現在就偏軟體跟AI服務的收入
看他的營收的走勢YY
也確實發現越來越好了
整個連增率也已經到目前有26%左右
第二劑呢
EPS的部分也連增將近一倍
EPS3.4 創價單劑新高
各位看一下
他今年的上半年已經賺5.93
351693 6.95.93
換句話說
今年有機會賺一個資本額非常高
因為他每一劑
他通常可以賺到2塊錢左右
如果這樣的話
我們再看他的股息配發
今年配發5塊半
坦白講 過去也算是高股息值利率的部分
如果他發放
你可以到八成過去的配發的這個
去年的水準的話
那麼今年利率PS
如果機會達到四塊的話
那八塊錢的股利
那股息值利率大概就將近有5%
那北易比大概就15倍
我們來看一下這樣公司
蠻強勢的
如果不是今天的IPC
話漢有這樣下跌的話
坦白講
今天的IPC不容易出現
這樣大幅的一個
這個走路
但是坦白講
他這邊已經是已經突破前波的高點格局
而且這邊有大量贏過了
換句話說這邊也有大量
那只是說今天是真的是受到
整個市場上信心不足的問題
所以我跟你講覺得如果是這樣的話
剛好拉回到前波的這個支撐位置
倒是可以去留意一下到後面的買翻
因為我剛剛提到過
如果他明年有機會配到八塊錢
坦白講現在的直率力已經不到
這個已經直率力已經有5%以上
那另外一家是不是蓮華
是 那林華之前跟輝達
已經在做合作
那我們發現確實合作完之後
確實他營收
每個月營收都是兩位數的高幅度成長
那目前的營收大概九十三億
那去年營收一百一十八億
我大概運過
他今年到九月份的時候
媒體應該就會報導
他的營收超越
整個去年全年部分
那這家公司也確實已經有在做一個改變
因為運算模組化電腦
以及自動化產品出貨同步成長
你可以發現
它的盈利 毛利率的部分
0.61 5.57 12.1
你會發現現在都是倍數在成長
換句話說它今年的上半年專1.57
這部分有機會
來超越先前的高點位置
法人預估甚至有機會挑戰七塊錢
這幾年當中最好成績
那本益比大概在20倍左右
那它責力率大概目前是2.5左右
我們看一下他的走勢
他的走勢
就是有點震盪比較大
不太像工業電腦
像這一波的時候
這一波其實長很急
大家都很意外
是啊
我覺得某種成績
某種在反映到他的成績
但另外這一波來講
他的低檔有大量
而且我記得有一天
他好像跌停板
在洗那個籌碼
然後這邊有一個大量
那現在這個位置
在高在這個附近
所以我個人覺得
如果以剛剛講的
今年一PS有機會挑戰七塊
其實現在目前本益比也差不多20倍左右
那現在就是變成前波這邊有套老量
但是那地檔也有一些大量
換句話說會轄幅在這邊做整理
如果以這個位置來講的話
區間整理的話
這位置效率相對高還是效率相對低
看頭最就很清楚了
其實這一波的話
反攻的量溫溫的
可是供應電腦以前冷冷的
現在反而它的量通通跑出來
代表市場有非常關注他們
好 這邊非常謝謝鐘總
好 謝謝趙豪